who do you think is the greatest MMA
fighter of all time
Craig let's start with you just as a fan
of the sport as somebody's been deep in
it I mean from my perspective after that
performance I'm gonna say volkanovski
because he was able to decisively
outstrike Max Holloway one of the
greatest Strikers in the sport and he
was able to hang with the wrestling of
Islam makachev and in terms of Ortega
was able to survive Ortega who has some
of the most dangerous emissions in Jiu
Jitsu so I think in my opinion
technically he's the best
so even though even though he
technically lost he's still he still has
a crown I I believe in himself given the
size difference given he's moving up in
white yeah I think all those factors
really the underdog everything the
pressure
did you think he would be able to hang
in any of the wrestling exchanges with
Islam No no no I was really surprised
that's why my eyes like
it's kind of funny like winning at the
end of the day I feel like judges
influence that although I did think
Australian judges would Rob the other
way but yeah I was assuming they kind of
somebody paid somebody and not enough
maybe but uh but in general I just
thought he won sort of in the eyes of
what martial arts stands for like
sort of going to the fire and survive
and and Thrive and finish the last round
strong which is kind of like spiritually
is what a victory is so I was I wish we
kept going like one more round yeah
exactly that kind of thing
um well what about you what do you think
like who are the fighters you admire
like who do you think is the greatest of
all time I think the fighter I paid most
attention to was Jon Jones
um you know he has a great ability just
to mix the the high level striking high
level grappling
um although his you know Jiu Jitsu by
itself isn't you know probably isn't
like you know super high level but his
ability to mix everything together I
would say he's he's the best
and he's a fellow you know heavier guy
heavyweight now so it's it's nice to see
you know how those guys move at that
weight
and it fellow natural athlete
see what I did there all right uh what
about what about you Nikki yeah if I had
to pick a goat I would probably have to
say khabib uh just because he was he was
undefeated and he had a very you know
High finishing rate you know very few of
his fights actually went to a decision
um so he just overall he dominated
almost every single opponent he won
against the Dominus